whose first games link
[Music]
then out of 12 for the San Antonio Spurs
Lanza trying to find some room down the
middle goes hang in the air he scores
LeBron 10 on the clock of agreement it's
in OT lonzo's gonna try it for you
I like him he doesn't hesitate cuddly
and that's what force the mist by
DeRozan Lonzo though the cat
[Applause]
LeBron line lobs it in lawns with good
position for the mismatch against
painting LeBron he sought Lonzo did too
and one is through her past even good
looking good use of the height advantage
by Lazo against the three-point
opportunities have to keep tightening
the screws in this end of the floor go
defense to offense and the Lakers lead
by 13 Lonzo kick by the key to key role
in Lonzo goes to the rim sup we wanna
see doesn't even 40 yet alter that was
because Jackson did a good job of
challenges making steel breakout
Stephenson he's gonna give it up off the
balls Oh Showtime
Lansing's Oh sparkling about one off the
glass and so just hammers it try to go
into the - - Lance I think we've tapped
into it begin with a lot of traffic
[Applause]
and change it's got 14 boys Jamal Murray
with that three right there in 16 shot
on a 12 Bucky look at that
build the contact enabled to finish
pushing free-to-play mr. Ness right here
step back
[Applause]
for the Lakers the double-vision right
back to see ah from Phelps good read by
Lanza very good read and Zoey who scores
it
Dastur for ronzo ball with the Linda
finish this here starter for the Lakers
beep sighs OH knock it down he's got it
you can tell it the crowd are still
holding out hope why not
stolen away by heart their couple acres
seen stranger things happen
what pilot is cornered Lonzo another one
he's got three and that forces a timeout
get it done as Lonzo brings him to
within 14
[Music]
[Applause]
raps a little further away that in what
a tune he's still crew it down
Brandon mount Alonzo attacks great pad
the finish by McGee and that's three
assists in a row for Alonzo ball comes
to Vale the Hawks are going to rely on
live to be to playmakers they're in
trouble because yes sir
he always been shot won't go Thompson's
tip misses him McGee able to bring it
down foul down the other end
Lonzo gonna come to get it ball on the
perimeter central shoot lines are he's
gonna spin left hand
it's beautiful stop dog man was out
about afternoon game here at staple
sentence birds in the air comes up short
hit Laker defense
ronzo here he goes with some speed
[Applause]
went right back to ball took off from
seemingly the dotted line this is a nice
tap by cooling rate great job the Lakers
trail by three
Barnes works himself hit low and they're
gonna take it away from DJ wheat sit
down de la slow ball with some speed
Lonzo all the way he's gonna finish on
the break now he can push it up the
floor Danny as played by Alonzo when he
gets the ball on the mishandled by the
Andre Jordan it takes it the length of
the floor with his left ball off the
screen the slimes old prism that slope
what luc1 and the lake is one of the do
turns the corner and attacks the
Aldridge screen James with it and
busting out this time Paul fires
scattered
[Applause]
because started four before they're just
one for six number cloths and stats
weapon is bad Lanza counted foul nice
blade set up out of the timeout good
view
hook the pants the affinity bow comes up
short again Koosman out of heart it's
three on to the gone down the middle
right side that's the way you run a fast
break the Lakers go up by eight as
LeBron to Lonzo and back to LeBron great
Popovich is very happy about
telegraphing it Lonzo is and so is
LeBron you still got a lot of cuts a
little less than five minutes and you've
got this guy on the team good pass to
size it down pretty good defense without
fouling ball they take it away lead
[Applause]
rip it away from Gasol that LeBron finds
lonzo's going to come to the floor give
a job good job by JaVale though the
challenged at 3/4 you got a seven footer
with that kind of wingspan coming at
look at that play in transition where
LeBron throws it up to the lanza talked
about longer their franchise leader in
rebounds is goood honest hands on bruza
still with the team up with 16 years
ronzo take that three buckets found 9
for 21 from downtown here's ball on the
drive ball pretty play that's with coach
rotten wants to see more from ball
playing downhill had the confidence
distance hacking attacking this ball he
got the step and he scores
[Applause]
entire traps told me the way by so
[Applause]
throw it down we talked about his
instant solutions that's bridges playing
above the rim protects the rim and so
Marte that's some recovery by JaVale
McGee leather look at that play by
available look at this makes the play
without committing the foul that's the
most impressive the God will watch them
they drive to the basket more than any
teams in the league nice if we Kim was
sitting there saying I got you
there's the street or right between tool
cody zeller i just run for the cover run
for cover Cody you don't want to be on
that poster
the 21 you're all from Chino Hills they
don't have that bona fide go-to guy they
have to play of that play by lonzo's he
finds the open Tyson Chandler have to
bring in two defenders to him once do
you go up to shoot the ball and it
leaves your head you've set both feet
and you made a breath he had 32 Sunday
in there
over
Paul answers back with a three of his
own it was wide open for don't hear the
quarter until thought about it Lonzo now
we'll take the key stop by the bar again
this time three
and here come the Lakers not score the
Lakers 44 to 18 imperative to get a good
score right here bouncing Africa the
Angelo Russell turned his head
completely kcp got to do something here
with and you got to do it purpose lot so
for three and I don't care if you're a
small market or a big market as the
Lakers get out transition nice play
another assist for LeBron James
I Bruce a great guy remember he took go
that that started the year off a couple
years ago when his wife is dealing with
[Applause]
New Orleans calls for time the Memphis
little frigid from the perimeter law
they're the slowest pace is you've been
mentioning his solos underneath the
score
I did a good job of getting real deep
print position three of the veterans
available passes been perfectly no son
defense to offense and the Laker leaders
for radical rivers kuzmic are the best
by cauley-stein nice rim run button that
I said janitor
[Applause]
bring his shots he's not attacking the
rim like he did in the previous two
games Alonso he's going to attack it's
Calvin uptown
nice read by Lanza that time was can we
show Lonzo getting good penetration and
throwing it up with the left hand you
know what he misses layups he usually
misses a wood is right he saved the
turnover for yourself didn't he was
showing it now where Lanza created a
sensational behind-the-back padlock
LaRoche
Lonzo didn't bank that with anything
step back and drained it was a good
rebounder as well comes away with a
board ball pushes goes right to the rim
first of speed and a chance for a
three-point play looked to be a scorer
taking it to the body the contact and
going to the line it's a shot 18 three
throws in the quarter they take but you
rebound by Josh sharp open his Lonzo
deep down Lakers down by two
[Applause]
that's the way they'll have to attack
through the points two assists seven
minutes fifty protectable war early
going Lotso balls and he had to take
that long a shot anything to do with it
another look at that three-pointer with
the clock really low he's paying that
kind of energy throughout Lakers down
two with the basket all right so up the
alley oop the past our welder cos Derry
tried to jump get a look at that pass in
Josh art to hunt so and he just dark
morality then you got
[Applause]
for the first time tonight Los Angeles
empty possession by the Lakers is bisley
Beasley misses now canard swatted from
behind by ball and a great bounce pass
ahead delay
for caldwell-pope speed on this plate
but gets back into the picture with a
big time block and how about the vision
great pass the poll of all the coaching
moves today there were there were none
as JaVale McGee puts it in with a head
of steam here's Galloway he's pinned
their best offensive player in the
second half look at that pass down court
about llamas old ball from one end to
the other a touchdown Lee habit does
pretty much instant offense for the
Lakers recently see they're more
consistent scores his ronzo firing in
store and that was only to beat the shot
clock a couple of nights ago in Detroit
was it down to a grip a bit of a gap
not down up a high Lonzo as his second
three-pointer in three attempts exactly
Lily
Wendell Carter jr. attention casual
rookie ever to Scott
[Applause]
Bulls with the one-point lead foot best
cross-court so good fake Ingram ball
fake finds himself open Dan hit the 3/4
pass right up house by so to the open
Kuzma exactly where his teammate is he's
looking right at him
drones at to him for the easy deuce to
Lakers trail by one
Raja listen speed downhill he goes he
was surrounded by a trio of all the
gorge speed is what got that basket
specifically communicating they should
be ok of these season goes
thanks pass up the blocks of all a Tyson
Chandler talking with Luke Walton is
affliction
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the other caldwell-pope how about
the assist this is why everybody loves
supply to Lulu
caldwell-pope for the deep three hits
that's a second trip downtown but a good
job
bat-ball again it's all gonna be blobby
citizens wallet Franco by the Lakers yes
matzo ball showing emotion Oh play you
cannot grow unless you are the ball okay
seeds offensive lines Oh ball nice
little fake and banker that is so hard
to guard when you drive it hard stop and
give it away again ball races up the
floor lamp is good off of make that took
about four seconds